i'm excited to welcome the president's
infrastructure implementation
coordinator mitch landrieu to the
briefing room as you all know mitch
served as the 61st mayor of new orleans
under his leadership new orleans is
widely recognized as one of the nation's
greatest comeback stories recovering
from hurricane katrina and the bp oil
spill mitch served as president of the
u.s conference of mayors was named
public official of the year in 2015 and
was voted america's top turnaround mayor
in a survey of mayors in 2016. prior to
serving as mayor
he served two terms as lieutenant
governor of louisiana and in the
louisiana house of representatives for
16 years as the president's
infrastructure coordinator mitch
oversees the largest long-term
investment in america's infrastructure
and competitiveness in nearly a century
i wanted to have him come speak with all
of you following our announcement on
friday of more than 27 billion dollars
from the bipartisan infrastructure law
to fix an estimated 15 000 bridges
across the country and ahead of the
president's meeting later this week with
the infrastructure implementation task
force which he co-chairs with that i
will turn it over he's agreed to take a
few uh questions before he has to go
build some more bridges
of okay go ahead
good morning everybody
so this is what this room looks like
i've been wondering for a while it's
nice to see happy new year to you um my
name is mitch
the president asked me to help him build
a better america
i said yes
i hope the people of america agree to
because it's going to take all of us
to get this done
when president biden came into office
just one year ago he pledged to use the
power of the presidency to help everyday
americans to bring people together
and to rebuild our country for decades
we just talked about infrastructure week
but president biden reached across the
aisle and in a bipartisan way actually
got it done
promises made
promises kept
let me tell you every week now is going
to be infrastructure week except the
difference is we're actually going to
build stuff
with a bipartisan infrastructure law
president biden is delivering the
largest investment in infrastructure in
a generation that means in most of our
lives a little more than 60 days ago
our team hit the ground running to
deliver results
we have now convened the task force made
up of cabinet members a total of six
times this thursday will be our seventh
and the president will be with us
we're discussing hard questions seeking
to flesh out the tough stuff first i'm
afraid
in running to the fire not away from it
we're breaking down silos across
agencies on guidelines on permitting on
hiring this is a one-team one-fight
mission and we're going to operate in
that way
we also need good partners the fact of
the matter is
that most of the building will actually
be done by the states by the cities by
the counties by the tribal leaders
that's why our team and me personally
have been reached extensive outreach to
state and local officials at this point
we have reached out to all 50 governors
and their key staff
i have spoken to hundreds of elected
officials uh and we have gotten a
fantastic response from them all as you
know by now we have asked states to
appoint infrastructure coordinators
which we think will help foster
cross-agency collaboration and make it
easier for them to get problem solved
very quickly
already states like delaware and new
mexico have appointed coordinators in
states like arkansas and michigan are
setting up interagency task forces our
team is here to be problem solvers to
deliver to build the team and to help
tell the story ultimately we want to
help people take advantage of this great
opportunity to build a better america
now
as a country we haven't spent this
amount of money on infrastructure in
generations so we're talking about how
to do it with accountability and
transparency on time on task on budget
spending taxpayer dollars both wisely
and well
earlier today i convened the inspectors
general of federal agencies involved in
the implementation of the law
letting them know we want to do this in
a partnership just like the president
did when he was the vice president he
led the recovery act process as the
president has expected from his team
since day one including the
implementation of arp
as the president has made clear results
and accountability go hand in hand to
deliver results now and in the years to
come the federal government must
undertake this work in a manner that is
deserving of the public's trust so we're
going to lean forward stewardship of
public dollars is a high priority
but i want to level set
this infrastructure work in general is
not
a one-time economic stimulus it is not a
race to see how many ribbons we can cut
before the end of the year
doing this is going to require balance
it's going to require order we are
definitely going to go fast but we are
not going to hurry and we are going to
get it right
on the nuts and bolts we're on the right
track as the president laid out last
week we've made real progress you've
seen the announcements rebuilding roads
ports and airports we're making progress
on delivering high-speed internet to
every american we're making progress on
ensuring water systems deliver clean
water by replacing lead pipes and of
course on friday the president rolled
out the massive 27 point billion dollar
allocation to states to fix over 15 000
bridges the largest bridge program
in american history
you see bridges connect us they connect
people the movement of goods they
connect communities they connect the
country with this investment president
binding is creating a bridge to the
future a pathway to win
a pathway for all of us to win
and today we have another great
announcement the department of interior
is announcing a new interagency program
for cleaning up orphaned wells a key
initiative of the bipartisan
infrastructure law the law includes 4.7
billion dollars to clean up off and well
sites plugging remediation and
restoration activities
so what does this mean for the people of
america
millions of us millions
live within a mile of hundreds of
thousands of often and abandoned wells
that leak and spew
these wells jeopardize public health and
safety by contaminating groundwater
seeping toxic chemicals chemicals
emitting harmful pollutants including
methane this well-capping program also
creates jobs and we will revitalize
rural economies in places where people
are directly affected transitioning
economy
so many of these issues we face cleaning
it up will take an all
of government approach
interior secretary deb holland is
leading this effort in close partnership
with the department of agriculture epa
and the department of energy and already
26 states have asked for fundings to
take advantage of this opportunity to
clean up this mess
secretary holland told me the other day
a story about a school she visited where
children had tissues in their nostrils
due to constant
nosebleeds a result of contamination can
you imagine having our children have to
learn in this kind of environment it has
gone on for quite a long time
that's why we're doing this real results
where people live and where it really
matters cleaning up communities fighting
climate change creating new and better
jobs and building a bridge to a future
economy it's a really consequential
effort and later this week there will be
more announcements to come
in closing let me just say the president
has been clear in his charge
to me build a better america
without unnecessary bureaucracy and
delay while at the same time doing what
is difficult
for the sake
of what is right
and so better as we have said many times
means creating good middle class jobs
investing in american manufacturing and
building capacity right here at home
supporting disadvantaged and underserved
communities so that no one and no
community is left behind advancing
climate resilience and sustainability so
that we can be better prepared and ready
for whatever is coming our way
all of this will make us stronger and
better reduce costs for the middle class
families and help us compete
this
is what building a better america looks
like for all of us
thank you jen back to you all right
uh jeff go ahead
mr mayor thank you very much
um you could tell us what the response
from some states
in your whole neck of the woods has been
we've seen many federal programs
obamacare one example other things some
red state governors have been resistant
are you seeing a different kind of
response on things like infrastructure
which the programs of which are popular
but the
administration isn't necessarily and
just give us a time frame of when you
think some
of these ribbon cuttings i know that's
not the metric but when will they be
happening anything this year
jeff thank you so much for that a very
wise person said you know even if they
vote vote no they want the doe
and that
that's absolutely true especially on
infrastructure as i said i have
personally spoke to over 40 governors
three the chiefs of staff the others uh
we have been contacted through staff
i've talked to a number of republican
governors all of whom
uh in the reddest of red states were
very welcoming they're very appreciative
that the president had asked the call
we clearly acknowledged with each other
that we may have differences of opinion
on other issues but on building roads
and bridges and airs and airports in
clean water and broadband
you know 75 percent 80 percent of the
people of america want these things to
happen and the governors have committed
to work with us to actually get it done
you mentioned that uh in my neck of the
woods i'm from the state of louisiana as
you know we have gotten beaten to death
by katrina rita i guess off the national
recession the bp oil spill and a bucket
load of other stuff we always wonder
when the locusts are coming
and we have had we have had uh
interaction as i was lieutenant governor
with a republican governor who i served
within the democratic governor in both
of those instances bipartisanship really
is at the forefront of these initiatives
they're going to be some differences but
at the end of the day there really is
common ground and i feel very good about
um the willingness to lean forward and
to do the things that all of our
constituents need irrespective of what
party that they're in in terms of
turning dirt quickly as i said to you to
level set with everybody in this room
because you will ask me about this from
time to time can you hurry up when's the
money going to get it to the ground when
are the first ribbon cuttings first of
all this is very different from the
american recovery program this is a
long-term investment in rebuilding
america better and so there are a lot of
these programs that are actually new
many of them are not
this happens in two ways some of this is
through formula funding that has been
set
every governor has received an
indication of what the states are going
to receive for the next five years and
that's across whoever sitting in the
governor's share so they can start
planning today and actually start
breaking ground as soon as they're ready
to do that
the other part of this bill is
competitive grants some of those are
going to take a little bit of time to
set up my expectation is there's some
there's some projects that you'll see
people turning dirt on uh indefinitely
the spring of the fall which ones they
are i can't actually point to you right
now but there's no reason why that
shouldn't happen especially if some of
the projects have been in the line for
some period of time
to that point you know the president
promised shovel ready projects the
administration hasn't yet been able to
identify which of those projects might
be getting underway soon when will we
get a better sense of what projects are
coming i can't give you an exact date
but as i said to you
with the announcements that have
happened in the first 60 days and you
have a list of what those announcements
so i don't need to repeat them but you
remember the investments that we made in
ports and the investment that we just
made in bridges and the ones that we
sent out the ones that michael regan
sent out on clean water and clean air
the governors now have this money on top
of that some of this money is fungible
from the american recovery plan as well
so as soon as the governors and the
legislatures decide where this money is
going to go and they do it with
appropriate attention
to equity climate
using american products and and other
things of that nature
those projects shouldn't take long
however
it takes a long time to build a bridge
you know you don't build a bridge in a
day now sometimes people in this town
know that you can tear down things a lot
quicker than you can build them
and they work hard to do that in this
instance we're going to take time and do
it right but we're going to do it as
quickly as we possibly can
yeah thanks uh mayor i'm going to tell
you about the uh 66 billion dollars for
amtrak what does the process look like
in terms of spending uh those funds
again on the timeline when you think
that that uh those dollars will get out
and is it going to be in terms of
figuring out which projects i know they
have like you know planning that amtrak
does and a lot of it's focused on that
northeast
uh uh that travels up the northeast
coast you know is that going to be a
process that amtrak itself uh figures
out what they're going to spend or is
there going to be input also from the
administration the white house how does
that going to work well first of all
we're going to all figure it out
together yeah you can count on that
uh secondly just to make you aware
of the scope of this project it's 1.2
trillion there are 14 agencies plus some
that have some level of involvement in
many of these plans and programs it
takes three or four agencies to
coordinate and then there are some
independent agencies and amtrak is one
of those as you notice
they have 66 billion dollars to do a
really really big job and of course you
won't be surprised to know the president
has a special interest in trains um and
he'll talk to you about it for a very
very long time and he knows more about
it than many engineers
in an unbelievable way we've started
those conversations with amtrak you have
rightly noted that the northeastern
corridor is the one that needs immediate
attention the president however has also
indicated that he's really interested in
trying to make sure that we look at
where the connections are that connect
moving people that's cheaper faster
and is also climate frenzy so we're in
the process of of kind of putting that
together um and we'll have a plan in the
in the not too distant
that could be started this year or more
likely something i think a lot again i
don't want to speak specifically for
amtrak it's an independent agency there
are many things that can be started
right now um and as i have said to you
in some of these models that we have in
some formulas that money has actually
already been indicated and sent out of
the door so that's just going to be a
matter of administrative uh work that we
have to do thank you should be the last
one
based on what you've seen so far how
many state governments
have the capacity already to
evaluate this huge number of projects
all at once and determine which ones are
most worthy of the funding because as we
saw for example with the american rescue
plan you might be very organized here at
the federal level but if they don't have
the
staffing and the know-how and the
capacity at the state level there will
be bottlenecks great that is a fantastic
question and thank you for asking this
as you heard me say throughout this talk
it's all going to be about balance how
do you go fast and how do you get it
right how do you really try to do the
right thing but at the same time not go
too slow how do you deal with actually
getting money to the ground quickly and
making sure that people have the
capacity to use it let me say this again
to all of us who were younger than 80
years old you have not seen this in our
lifetime
and when we have tried to do this in the
past because we haven't spent a lot of
time building up what i call downline
logistics you hear me say this many many
times sometimes up here in washington
they want to create a cow and when it
gets down to the ground it looks like a
pig and the point is to make sure that
what we're trying to do down here gets
down to the ground with the people from
the ground up understanding it knowing
it analyzing and working in partnership
with them one of the things that should
be obvious to anybody in this country is
that we have a capacity problem on the
ground notwithstanding the current
circumstance that we're in even if the
world were perfect you have to say to
yourself are we ready to build this much
stuff this fast and the answer is if you
if you triage it appropriately if you
plan appropriately if you run to the
fire and one of the fires is do we have
enough people do we have enough
materials and if we don't how do we
create workforce training programs how
do we build capacity how do we
manufacture products here and you
understand that this is a five to ten
year cycle you can actually move into it
if you do it intentionally and with
thought so to answer your very specific
question um there are some states that
have been in this business for quite a
long time and have moved big stuff and
they're obviously more prepared than
others one of the great challenges and
one of the great missions the president
gave us because and it falls under the
umbrella of equity and climate what
about these small indigenous communities
that don't have the capacity to apply
for a grant what happens if they get a
grant do they have the ability to spend
the money and our team has raised that
up all of our agencies and says we've
got to run to that fire and we have to
start building capacity on the ground
level and then how actually are we going
to do that what does workforce training
like what does the partnership with
community and technical colleges look
like how is labor going to build
apprenticeship programs to lift up
people of color who have not been
involved in this interest and how do you
create this virtuous cycle of success
and moving in one direction this is why
back to jeff's questions earlier if
everybody cooperates if everybody saves
the the the fire for all of these hot
button issues that that we all tend to
disagree with and don't focus that on
infrastructure because there's not a
republican or a democratic way to fill a
damn pothole then we ought to be able to
get all of this stuff done more quickly
um and and and better and that ladies
and gentlemen is what a better america
looks like for president biden thank you
all very much i appreciate it thank you
invited back any time as i always like
to say okay um
all right is this a little bit better
this time okay
uh just have a couple of items for all
of you at the top i have a bit of a
heart out at quarter over 10 of so we'll
get around to as many people as possible
um i know that many of you are tracking
that we are uh about to reach our uh one
year mark here in the administration and
we just wanted to note a couple of the
points of progress that have been made
that you'll hear the president talk more
about and members of our administration
also talk more about over the coming
days and you know how we left charts
around here so we have some charts that
lay out a pretty stark contrast between
where we started and where we are now uh
so just to highlight a couple of pieces
during the president's first year we saw
the most dramatic change in our economy
of anywhere in the world it was the
biggest year of job growth in american
history and it was the direct result of
actions taken by president biden and
democrats in congress including the
american rescue plan the vaccination
effort it helped fund and now the
bipartisan infrastructure law
and you can see uh the economic data
there uh quite starkly i mean look at
the initial unemployment claims they're
on average uh they're 800 or they were
at 812 000 a year ago they're now at 210
000. the unemployment rate and obviously
job creation the year before the
president took office and the last year
as it relates to covid if we look to a
year ago only one percent of adults were
fully vaccinated 74 of adults are fully
vaccinated now in terms of at home tests
on the market now we've talked about
tesla zero on the market a year ago now
we have 375 million people per month or
test or distribute i should say per
month
46 of schools were open a year ago now
over 95 percent uh this is progress
that's been made obviously there's more
work that's going to be done that needs
to be done the job is not done yet but
we have a plan to address the challenges
we're facing and we're going to stay at
it with that colleen why don't you kick
us off
um i wanted to ask about negotiations
over voting rights to see
you know what you guys are expecting
this week um and then
what's plan b
if if things go south you know to secure
elections and ensure
voting access if the bills don't pass
well as you all know the the negotiation
or the debate is starting in the senate
the president's view is that the
american people deserve to see
where their leaders stand on protecting
their fundamental rights that is a
reason to move forward with this debate
and this vote this week and it's views
also that opposing rule changes to make
the protection of voting rights a
reality is supporting an
obstacle to protecting voting rights
it's part of the important process in
terms of uh what so we will continue to
and you've heard the president say and
i'm sure he will reiterate for you if
anyone asks him tomorrow that until his
last breath he will be fighting for the
protection of voting rights and that
means conversations and fighting to get
legislation at the federal level through
is going to continue and those
conversations will continue i will note
that in addition uh we have also been
working uh with organizations all across
this country who are building diverse
coalitions to pass voter voter laws and
push back against those that make it
harder to vote and threaten free and
fair administration of elections in
addition to doing the critical work to
register and educate voters these
organizations have built grassroots
leadership at the state level
they're providing training policy
research messaging guidance and
directing organizing to register voters
deploy voter protection teams in states
that are rolling back voter protection
i'd also note the vice president knows
americans at every level are focused on
this fight and she will continue
engaging and leading this effort with
activists policy leaders and elected
officials around the country but right
now our focus is on the debate on the
vote that is uh going to be happening
and on the fact that it will highlight
very clearly for the american people uh
who stands with them and protecting
their voting rights and who stands
against
it um
what do you hope to achieve with the
secretary of state heading not only to
ukraine but then later to geneva to meet
with um lavrov especially since you know
talks with over ukraine aren't exactly
going all that well right now um well
let me just give you a little bit of an
update on where things stand and
obviously you're following this closely
but this morning secretary blinken uh
spoke with russian foreign minister
lavrov they agreed to meet in geneva uh
as you as you noted at that meeting
secretary blinken will urge russia to
take immediate steps to de-escalate he
will also fly to keeve to consult with
president zielinski and ukraine's
leaders and to germany for consultations
as you also know there is a
congressional delegation that is also uh
on their way there um and it's a note i
would note that that just indicates that
support for ukraine has always been a
bipartisan issue and we welcome that but
where things stand right now president
putin has created this crisis by
amassing a hundred thousand russian
troops along ukraine's borders this
includes moving russian forces into
belarus recently uh for joint exercises
and conducting additional exercises on
ukraine's eastern border so let's be
clear our view is this is an extremely
dangerous situation we're now at a stage
where russia could at any point launch
an attack in ukraine and what secretary
blinken is going to go do
is highlight very clearly there is a
diplomatic path forward it is the choice
of president putin and the russians to
make whether they are going to suffer
severe economic consequences or not
uh go ahead let me go around to people
uh trevor
uh could you when you're talking about
um kind of this meeting that uh the
secretary of state is going to have with
sergey lavrov what is the um is there an
expectation that he's going to provide
some sort of response to the issues that
were raised in the
january 10
meeting
oh well
again i don't have anything for you to
specifically preview on the
behind-the-scenes negotiations and
discussions but our position uh has been
crystal clear uh from the beginning the
position of the president and the
secretary of state that there are two
paths there's a diplomatic path forward
we certainly hope they take that path
there's the other path it is up to the
russians to determine which path they're
going to take and the consequences will
be severe if they don't take the
diplomatic path
there's been reporting out of europe
that um
essentially this idea that's been
floated about taking russia out of the
swift financial payment system is
basically off the table at this point is
that accurate no option is off the table
in our view we continue consulting
closely with european counterparts on
severe counter consequences for russia
if it further invades ukraine
from the german government that they
will end the nordstrom 2 pipeline
i think as you know it is not
functioning currently you've seen the
steps that they have taken uh recently
uh the pipe uh germany's federal network
agency has suspended the certification
process as well of nordstream ii um and
our view continues to be that stopping
the nordstrom 2 pipeline is a critical
pr credible piece
we hold over russia at this point in
time especially since it is not
functioning and if sanctions are imposed
right now which some are proposing and
russia views these sanctions as a sunk
cost then this would be one less
consideration in its calculus so of
course we're consulting closely with all
of our partners and allies in this but i
would just note again
that the pipeline's not operational that
germany's federal network agency has
suspended the certification process go
ahead thanks i'm staying on ukraine and
russia what does the white house make of
the evacuation of uh russian diplomatic
staff from their embassy in kiev and do
you think the threat of invasion is
getting higher or lower
well i think as i noted a few minutes
ago we believe we're now at a stage
where russia could at any point launch
an attack on ukraine
i would say that's more stark than we
have been uh in terms of the decision uh
to move um
uh uh to move it uh to evacuate their
embassy or to move personnel out of
their embassy we have information that
indicates uh the russian government was
preparing to evacuate their family
members from the russian embassy in
ukraine in late december and early
january uh we certainly would refer you
to
them for more specifics about what their
decision is but we don't have an
assessment on why in the meeting
another one on reports that the white
house is in talks with the faa and
wireless providers on the 5g rollout and
those potential disruption to airline
travel is there anything more you can
tell us on this agreement you're working
on and are you trying to prevent any
flight cancellations which could start
as soon as tomorrow
uh well we are those conversations are
ongoing i don't have an update at this
moment but they're ongoing right now i
would say so uh we have the safest uh
airspace in the world uh we're committed
to reaching a solution around 5g
deployment that maintains the highest
level of safety while maintaining
disruptions while minimizing disruptions
to passenger travel cargo operations and
our economic recovery we certainly
understand what's at stake for both
industries uh we are actively engaged as
you said with the fa fcc wireless
carriers airlines and aviation equipment
manufacturers to reach a solution and we
believe uh that with continued uh
cooperation we can chart a path forward
but certainly uh minimizing flight
disruptions ensuring uh safety and
travel is a is a top priority
microsoft bank activision blizzard will
create the world's third biggest video
game company does the white house have
any competition concerns with this
acquisition
well i would just note that um today um
there is an announcement uh by the ftc
and the justice department that's
probably happening uh now uh broadly
speaking this is not about the specific
case uh which is in our view a critical
step towards delivering on one of the
key priorities of the of the executive
order the president signed which is
strengthening enforcement against
illegal illegal mergers and it basically
kicks off the technical process to
review merger guidelines as it relates
to this specific case that you mentioned
i don't have a comment on a specific
merger but i just wanted to point you to
their announcement their press
conference that may be going on right
now go ahead let me explain that i'll
let me go ahead so i just get to be
there
sure there's there's bipartisan supply
chain resiliency legislation in the um
in the house the us innovation and
competition act
is the white house engaged in getting
homemakers on tours with us very closely
engaged and we've been advocates for
investing in
manufacturing here in the united states
including investment in our chips
manufacturing uh capacity but we're very
closely engaged in these discussions
what kind of discussions you're having
and where there's just that we've been
engaged from the beginning uh the
president has long been an advocate for
uh increasing investment in our
manufacturing capacity at home and we
are looking forward to it moving forward
another one um does the president think
that members of congress should be
prohibited from trading stocks the
president is prohibited from doing this
so where does he stand on this and
should their spouses be too
the president uh didn't trade individual
stocks when he was a senator um that is
how he approached things he also
believes that uh everyone should be held
to the highest standard but he'll let uh
members of the leadership in congress
and members of congress determine what
the rule should be
go ahead michael thanks ben uh a couple
questions on what happened in texas
sure
um
how is it that an individual who was
known to mi5 in britain
uh who was on a watch list as of 2020
ended up in a synagogue in texas how did
that
well our understanding and obviously
we're still looking into this is that he
was checked against u.s government
databases multiple times prior to
entering the country and the us
government did not have any derogatory
information about the individual in our
systems at the time of entry we're
certainly looking at reference what
occurred to learn every possible lesson
we can to prevent attacks like this in
the future uh beyond that i'd certainly
refer you to the department of homeland
security obviously the president
referred to the incident as an act of
terror what is the significance of
referring to the individual as a
terrorist or
referring to the incident as a terrorist
incident i think and i talked to the
president about this um that day as well
i think there's no question that uh when
somebody
goes into a house of worship
um and threatens uh and holds hostage
individuals who are there uh that that
is an act of terror that is terrorism
that is why he called it that because we
don't need to be uh because it's very
clear it's what it is go ahead
hi thanks jen uh getting back to voting
rights for a minute yeah mentioned that
the white house administration is going
to continue to push back against state
legislatures the president mentioned
this as well last week but just to drill
down on that a little more can we expect
to see more litigation from the
department of justice around this and if
you look at cases that have already been
filed under section two we know
historically that takes a very long time
years to resolve are you confident that
there is any action you can take that
would
result in any outcome before the
midterms well i really refer you to
department of justice as you know they
have doubled their funding for voting
rights protections but in terms of
individual cases or legal intentions or
actions i would point you to them
to shift a little bit to healthcare and
the affordable care act that was
something that president bain ran on
expanding the aca he was able to do that
of course through the rescue plan but
some of those other pieces were tied to
build back better expanding medicaid
again addressing subsidies
is there a plan b a consideration of
what steps could be taken if buildback
better doesn't pass
well
here's the good news um there's a lot of
interest excitement and engagement with
a broad range of members of congress
about the shared desire to
get something done and to lower costs
for health care for elder care for child
care uh and those are a range of
conversations that are ongoing lots of
ideas uh that we're discussing and we're
engaged with um that is the status uh
the president proposed this as part of
his package because he as you said he
has advocated for he ran on he has
fought for an expansion of uh access to
health care uh lower costs for health
care he also feels very strongly about
lowering the cost of prescription drugs
something he thinks is frankly shouldn't
be controversial in this country if
you're not for lowering the cost of
prescription drugs what are you for
republicans in congress is his basic
fundamental questions so uh this is
something we will continue to discuss
we're continuing to fight for and work
for uh but you know i know there have
been a range of reports out there uh and
i would just make very clear there is no
specific proposal we are putting forward
we are just engaged in a range of
conversations with members of congress
about what to do next go ahead thanks
jen can you provide an update on the
covid testing website is it ready to go
has the hotline number been created you
know resiliency against crashes that
type of thing sure so uh codetest.gov is
in the beta phase uh right now which is
a standard part of the process typically
as it's being kind of tested uh in in
the early stages of being rolled out um
we didn't start from scratch here of
course the postal service already runs a
website that sells goods the public as
you know uh every website launch in our
view comes with risk we can't guarantee
there won't be a bug or two but the best
tech teams across the administration and
the postal service are working hard to
make this a success so it will
officially launch tomorrow morning it's
in the beta testing phase right now um
and i would also note that the u.s
digital service
which was an organization founded after
healthcare.gov
after the healthcare.gov rescue has been
supporting the postal service to ensure
that they have what they need to be
successful in this critical moment so
looking forward to an official launch
tomorrow morning uh and right now it's
in the beta phase
i'm ukraine and russia i know you said
that the the united states is ready for
uh russia to engage at any time i wanted
to ask you though about the media
narrative uh
the falsifying or alleging that russia
is gonna say that ukraine is gonna
attack russia have you seen any
indications of that has that has that
narrative been put into work yet
we talked about this a fair amount on
friday because we've seen efforts to
push that narrative uh in the media and
in the public um and i think one of the
um
key roles we can play here is making
very clear that there is a long history
of propaganda from russian leadership uh
that they use it as a tool uh to spread
misinformation uh as a as a as a means
of gaining grounds and we should be very
clear about what's accurate and
inaccurate and that's an inaccurate
narrative
go ahead thank you jen uh thank you
since there's so few reporters in here
today i'd like to ask uh briefly about
three transparency issues
um the first one i'm kind of amazed
hasn't been brought up more in this room
that is that vanity fair reported
recently that on october 22nd a group of
experts harvard rockefeller rockefeller
foundation and other groups proposed on
the zoo meeting with administration
officials a plan to mass distribute
coronavirus tests to homes before
christmas to prevent a winter surge of
coba 19 cases but that they were told
three days after that zoo meeting
that uh that idea was dead um so i
emailed you about this yesterday and
again this morning uh so that you'd be
able to track down a firm answer on two
details here
the first detail is uh which
administration officials attended that
october 22nd meeting for example did
doctors fauci and balinsky uh
participate and was president biden
personally briefed at the time on that
recommendation before it was passed over
well maybe people haven't asked about it
because we've done a lot of what was
discussed in that meeting that happened
a couple of months ago including
massively expanding our testing program
and capacity and the issue at the time
which was a very small part of the
conversation was that the market had not
expanded enough uh to uh to at that
moment in time be able to uh launch the
website we're launching tomorrow and the
president uh you know used the defense
production ask invested three billion
dollars to expand it quadrupled the size
of our testing capacity and now we've
ordered one billion doses so we see that
as our cova team the members who
participated saw that as a very
constructive meeting good meeting a lot
of which we've worked to implement
so the idea though to mass distribute
tests to homes before christmas and new
year's that idea was not adopted um how
can president biden shut down the virus
if he's you know not being briefed on
these ideas uh that i mean that's my
question so i'm wondering uh who were
the advisors and was president biden
briefed on this idea at the time well i
think i just answered your question uh
which you may not have been listening
maybe you were waiting to read your next
question which is fine but i just
answered your question let me finish let
me finish stephen stephen i'm finishing
uh what i said to you just a minute ago
is that we did not have the capacity at
the moment
we had a very constructive meeting with
this group
we agreed in the need to expand our
testing capacity that's why we
quadrupled the size of our testing
capacity and why the president had
already used the defense production act
to invest 3 billion
but the market did not have the capacity
at that moment to do what we're doing
tomorrow
but that's not the question i asked the
question i asked where's another
question i think i've answered your
question president briefed at the time
again i've answered your question if you
have another one i'm happy to answer it
otherwise i'm going to move on to the
next person i didn't get answers there
but i'll move on to another one great
the second question is uh that in light
of president biden's first year coming
to a close
the data indicates that he spent a
quarter of his days
at least partially in delaware in light
of that uh will the white house be
reconsidering the uh
the decision not to release visitor log
information from his delaware residences
well the president goes to delaware
because it's his home
it's also where his son and his uh
former wife are buried
and it's a place that is obviously close
to his heart a lot of presidents go
visit their home
when they are president we also have
gone a step further than the prior
administration and many administrations
in releasing visitor logs of people who
visit the white house and will continue
to do that go ahead in the back i think
we're done and we're going to move on uh
go ahead in the back the reuters
reported this morning the vita
administration is reviewing income
ecommerce giant alibaba cloud business
for uh
um
us national security reasons can you
confirm
i'd really have to check with our
national security team on that i'm happy
to do that and we'll get back to you
after the briefing
uh go in the back hey john um i want to
pivot back to voting rights particularly
um
uh the president's speech last week i
wonder if you can talk a little bit
about how it came together but also i
wonder if you'll respond to some of the
criticism about it that it was too
aggressive or divisive and that you know
some of the rhetoric that he used wasn't
you know conducive to getting folks you
know who are opposed on board
well
sorry which piece did you want me to
start with whichever one is best for you
uh okay well i would say first that um
you know the president delivered a
powerful speech about uh the protection
of people's fundamental rights in this
in this country which is their right to
vote the right to
to vote for anyone they choose whether
it is him or someone else it was not a
partisan speech it was intended to lay
out for the public exactly what's at
stake and lay out for elected officials
what's at stake
and he stands by everything he said in
that speech
can you talk a little bit about how it
came together though like who did he who
did he or the white house consult with
like how did he how did he land at this
point i'm just trying to get to the
genesis of it well he consulted there
have been discussions for months on
voting rights on the hill with democrats
certainly an open door to republicans to
have a discussion among members and
among staff about a path forward
something that 16 republicans who are
serving today have supported in the past
and also he consulted a lot with civil
rights leaders we consulted with civil
rights leaders with voting rights
activists and others who have been
working around the clock to advocate for
voting rights
okay go ahead jeff
i could ask you some questions first
what is the administration or the white
house doing today on the 5g controversy
uh if anything in the remaining hours
before the midnight deadline so there
are ongoing discussions right now with
members of our economic team uh who are
closely engaged
with um uh with at the faa fcc wireless
carriers airlines and aviation equipment
manufacturers to reach a solution as you
noted tomorrow is the deadline our
objective is of course to reach a
solution around 5g deployment that
maintains the highest level of safety
while minimizing disruptions to
passenger travel that's what we're
working towards but
everyone from secretary pete judge to
members of our economic team are closely
engaged in these discussions
and heading into the president's press
conference tomorrow on the eve of his
one year anniversary he has a long said
that he would
talk straight from the shoulder i think
that's his words uh that should be maybe
give an honest assessment of things what
is your honest assessment of the last
year of the biden administration um and
how can the voting rights of failure um
not be seen as some type of a metaphor
for these challenges
well i would say in terms of voting
rights um his view is that um it's never
a good idea not to shoot for the moon
with what your proposals are and what
you're fighting for and the alternative
is to fight for nothing and to fight for
nothing hard and that uh sometimes
oftentimes as you know you've covered a
couple of administrations you don't get
everything done in the first year but
what we feel good about and this is why
i brought some of these charts to show
the contrast is that coming into an
incredibly difficult circumstance
fighting a pandemic an economic
a massive economic downturn as a result
an administration that
was prior to us that did not effectively
deal with a lot of these crises that
there's been a lot of progress made
we need to build on that the work is not
done the job is not done and we are
certainly not conveying it is so our
objective and i think what you'll hear
the president talk about tomorrow is how
to build on the foundation we laid in
the first year
go ahead uh i'm on 5g the faa has had
two years to come up with a plan for
this to deal with this implementation
should they have acted sooner to
minimize disruption did the faa drop the
ball here you know i think uh mary
there'll be lots of time to look back
and see how we got here and i know many
of you will do that and and of course
that that is understandable but now
24 less than 24 hours what we're focused
on is uh trying to come to a solution
that will uh minimize uh travel uh
travel um uh you know uh disruptions to
passenger travel cargo operations on our
economic recovery and that is why it's
so important to hopefully come to an
agreement and ensure uh more planes are
flying out there
unless something has dramatically
changed which it doesn't seem likely
this is going to fail you have made
clear that the president you know is
going to keep up this fight
fight with every last breath he has does
that mean that this is the top priority
going forward legislatively i ask
because obviously is still stalled as
well where's the president putting his
energy
we can we can and will advocate for both
um and um that is reflective of what's
happening now too of course voting
rights is uh right now being debated
it's going to be on the floor uh the
president was out last week as you know
giving a powerful speech about why this
is so important to move forward at the
same time we were having a range of
conversations on buildback better
because we also want to get that done so
uh we're going to keep fighting for both
go ahead thanks jen
you know the airlines are using some
pretty dire language to describe what's
going to happen tomorrow if the
president doesn't step in and take
action they're saying that the nation's
commerce will grind to a halt that the
vast majority of the traveling and
shipping public will essentially be
grounded
does the president share the view
that the airlines have about how bad
this is going to be if the white house
doesn't step in well i think what we're
trying to do now is come to a solution
to avoid exactly that and it is true
that if there are
hundreds or thousands of flights that
are grounded that means not just
disruptions to passenger travel that
also means cargo operations that means
that goods aren't moving around as as
quickly and effectively uh as they need
to in order to not have supply chain
disruptions uh so this is something that
we are very focused on we've been
closely engaged on and we want to avoid
that and prevent it
the faa and the fcc seem to have
different views here the the faa seems
to share some of the concerns that the
airlines have about the possible
implications of
implementing 5g whereas the fcc has said
based on the data it's seen it's not a
problem
well i think part of this is as having a
negotiation and trying to find a
solution i'm not going to speak for the
fcc which is of course independent uh
our objective is to prevent this from
becoming uh the economic and disruption
that you referenced in your question
uh go ahead joey yeah thanks jim uh you
mentioned the beta testing is already
underway in regards to the covet 19
testing website one of my colleagues uh
discovered that they're already actually
you're you are already able to purchase
that or not purchase them order them for
free online uh so you know for people
who are purchasing them today is are
these orders being registered are they
going to be yeah that's that's beta
testing yeah so meaning we're going to
launch it formally tomorrow morning but
uh this is how we did vaccines.gov as
well so it's kind of a part of the
process did you have an official uh
rollout tomorrow morning what time in
the morning can we expect i don't have
the exact time for you at this moment
but um again it's going to be out
tomorrow morning um a mid morning
tomorrow and
uh we're looking forward to getting free
tests out to the public
maryland governor uh larry hogan
yesterday on face the nation said the
federal government has quote fallen
short in a couple ways recently in
regards to its covenant 19 response he
pointed to these 500 million uh
rapid tests saying the federal
government has purchased tests that his
state had already contracted rather than
purchasing new tests he said quote we're
sort of the test we already had plans
for we're now getting some of these
those providers to tell us they no
longer have the references so what is
the white house's response uh to that
criticism that the federal government is
purchasing
these same allotment of tests and
hamstringing uh some state efforts here
i'd have to check into that on the
accuracy of that with our kova team um
and i'm happy to do that all right
thanks so much everyone thank you
[Music]
you